Huda is a unique position in the
himalayas because of its biodiversity
and his trends on preserving the
environment by Constitution the 2008
Constitution 72% of the of Bhutan should
be kept as forests so it is amazing in
South Asia and when you fly from Bhutan
to any of the neighboring country you
know exactly where Whittle stops because
there is no forest anymore after that so
it's quite quite an amazing country but
it is also because buta has managed to
retain its independence and this is to
put to the credit of the past
governments and the kings
butas remain independent and can steer
its way to development in the way it
likes in a way data is incredible it is
its size is between Belgium and
Switzerland and it has 750 thousand
inhabitants but on this extremely small
superficial you go as you go it's
hundred kilometers across lies
north-south two knots and 200 kilometers
east to west and you go from 120 meter
elevation to 7400 elevation meter so
because of this incredible biodiversity
you have got a for example is just some
example in the South sure I've got all
the tropical fruit papaya banana mangoes
and so on and in the north of Central
you have got out of the temperate fruit
plums apricots uppers so just this give
you an example of the biodiversity on
such a small scale you have got tropical
forests and
I've got yaks and the step of the
Tibetan Plateau in the North you have
got glacier you have got deep jungle you
have got for example I was trapped in
one day which for Buddha is a long drive
it's about ten hours I did 10 km 200
kilometers in one day starting from the
South where I just met an elephant and
reaching the centre where they were yak
grazing in those things to do off
bamboos because yaks love to off bamboos
so it was that gives you an idea on such
a small small country it's literally an
environment hot spot it is fantastic
another very interesting point about
Buddha is that it is in the south on the
south slope of the Himalayas so it gets
at the same time cold weather from the
Tibetan Plateau and the wind especially
but with God also the monsoon so this
these climatic differences if you also
an incredible biodiversity
I would say in buta we live by the
biodiversity thing it doesn't mean it's
working all the time but we everybody
tries it's best the state as a user
government has a huge thing first of all
the Constitution 2008 Constitution says
that 72% of buta should be under forest
cover now how could you do that without
having a human wildlife conflict that we
have in buta it's not to shangri-la that
is clear you have human and we have
people having tough time with these
conservation issues so far the forest
things for example they give they have
devised the community forest so local
communities
even a forest next to their the common
forest which they can exploit according
to certain very strict guidelines but
they can enjoy reap the benefit of
having a community forest and they are
evaluated their work is evaluated by the
Ministry of Agriculture and forest so
they have a lot of guidelines and they
do a lot of empowerment of the local
communities by training trainings and
sending training people to train them
and to make them understand what is the
importance of the forest now this has
also and I would like to broach on this
question which is the crucial question
right now in buta said the human
wildlife conflict it is wonderful to
have so much forest but it is also a
problem and the second problem is that
due to religious beliefs
you cannot kill animals we have to win
you both to marry bears to really deers
too many elephants
not too many rhinos we have too many
wild dogs and this create a huge huge
problem for the farmers don't forget
that in 2060 percent of the population
still live off the land and when you
have worked all year on your field and
that in one night you see your crop
being destroyed by boss in the north
both as most all monkeys monkeys in the
East they come to your maize field and
the destroyed so for two months before
the crop people built small small shack
bamboo shacks in their field and they
sit there all night
with pots and pans to make noise to
frighten the animals it's a hard life
and sometimes they can't savage any crop
and I've seen a lot of people crying
because their crop was
give us in one night and that also bring
another problem a lot of people say why
should we stay in rural areas when we
have such a difficult life so that
brings the issue of rural urban
migration so of course we also call the
conservation policy which is fantastic
which is unique but the human factor is
starting to be better looked at by the
government in terms of compensation if
you lose things if you lose your crop if
you lose your cows and now another thing
which has come up is that recently about
ten years ago the Bhutanese have
discovered that Bengal tigers come up up
to four thousand meter through
biological corridor and the Tigers now
in central Bhutan in the valleys attacks
the cattle and sometime you find also a
little part in your kitchen or bear in
your kitchen and this is not one one
time stories these are real stories I'm
not making up here and so the Tigers are
also a menace for the cattle for the
cows and when you get ten cows killed by
a tiger the people have tough time when
you come and tell them you have to
protect the tiger so everything as we
say in Buddhism everything is
interdependent and this is a very good
illustration of interdependence of the
human and the wildlife and the forest
the wealth of Buddha eats his water and
it is his revenue earner and water is
the energy which is exported 80 percent
to India which is in great need of
energy the policy is to have
hydroelectric project
and by 2020 was to have 10,000 megawatt
of water energy this will not be
achieved probably and it creates was
also a lot of problem because people
have the country in the last five years
has developed a little too quickly in
terms of idle and that has created some
environment problem landslides
deforestation and other problems and
people the Bhutanese are not happy about
that so there is real now right now a
kind of free assessment of shall we go
all for final project hydroelectric
project shall we be only putting our
eggs in the basket of hydroelectric
project and this has come with the idea
which is really sinking down in the
population of this preservation of the
biodiversity and the environment because
Idol has created a lot of devastation
and it's not easy to build a brush or a
reservoir it's not done like that
there has been no not much population
shift because of the barrage it's not
like in China about hundred people have
been affected which in Bhutan is huge
but it's only hundred people and they
have got compensation landing
compensation but the Sun as soon as you
touch land issue in Bhutan it is
absolutely I would say it's in the genes
of the Bhutanese Earl and is so
important that it is a very very tricky
issue now another tricky issue which
goes with the awareness about
environment is a mining issue there is
not much ore in Bhutan but there is
limestone
especially slate limestone which is used
for us transformed for other things and
mining could be a huge revenue for the
government and some concession have been
given to private parties but now the
people in the village which are touched
by this mining are starting to grumble
and with the social media it becomes
much easier to know your rights and
wrongs so people have started to take
their grievance to the highest level and
being a small country it's easy to do
that and people want the mining to be
reassessed because they say our crop are
being depleted so dust is killing our
lungs and which country which land are
we going to give to our children because
of mining these are local people these
are villages articulating their problem
each such term which i think is
absolutely wonderful so there is right
now a total reassessment of mine mining
new guidelines are going to be draft and
probably the concession are going to be
reassigned now according to the new
policy